you
an Eastern bullet arena
fifty-two minutes remaining some tough
cookies here over 104 in there so I'm
gonna I'm gonna jump in here so you
could track tournament down if you want
right here Tournament Eastern bullet
arena boom alright let's see what kind
of games we could get in here
let's do it plus some mathematician the
Riemann hypothesis alright some bullet
let's get upon on e5
you
what maybe we go another step
schemes are so much faster
Bishop Bishop d7 quick jab at the Queen
83 or not I'm moving
Wow all right no III I'm gonna have to
move again maybe they mouse slipped
Queen a3 I get my majority going here
now it's not maturity but I have some
space on the Kings side now Queen only
has one safe move
having a tough time
bishop
having a tough day at the office okay
Brooke get a night next as close to me
yeah it's close to me very close to me
dangerous passer right here can't
survive this away
Pond still around still around still
around okay they're down on time
whoo okay
late joining just by 10 minutes is not
really much it's not shouldn't have that
big of an influence five games
it's an hour tournament so still got
another 50 to go uh what do you want to
do
Carol cone why not
why not
no not sure why let's just decline it
minority attack
the ball is rolling
a four or not f4 let's control f5 for
just a moment
alright let's follow through
chop
jump in do I get a good grip over this
square let's let's knock out a key
defender of e for exchange sacrifice or
not
yes let's remove the knight see if we
can make this a bit technical let's
centralize the Queen point at a - I got
my base point covered and pressure on
something let's see if I could just run
let's go here oh that's a big pond I
have this square now that's how you're
breaking this down let's offer clean
exchange they're gonna do that it gets a
little fuzzy it gets a little fuzzy a
little more fuzzy than I would like just
for fun well throw in a check and then
be a trading machine okay they're down
on time we got to two games in four
points what's the front page looking
like okay
21
Ferrari the fast and furious one is in
there he's been smacking me around the
last handful of games now we played no a
Budapest all right this is how I play it
on the white side
I don't even put up a fight I say you
just you take that pawn you you get that
pawn right back I don't care I don't
care
maybe I should care but I don't
[Music]
let's do something that's weakening
and then go here what my bishop on this
square
whose king is a little bit more weak I
think it is black
I hope to demonstrate why Tsun Tsun now
it's very uncomfortable for the Queen
yeah they're not quite sure what to do I
understand can I do another weakening
mouth I might want to insist on f6
yes so now we're getting there night
there needed was needed take like that
king of seven I think we're gonna have
another position where yeah there's this
exchange stuff I'm up the exchange oh my
god what am i I'm Way down on the clock
how did that happen can I get crazy with
my king
can I get made it
Wow my King's hungry
I'm almost made it at night is scaring
me
oh my god
why am i doing it like that
you
huh oh my god
Oh I was spending too much time at 5g
for g5 I should have been able to rattle
off those moves faster ah
quit commentating these are not blitz
games anymore put the foot on the gas I
meant to go one we're going to work with
it though we're going to go to
they could probably take care now
they're not taking their that they who's
they who is they
okay go queenside play for
oh my god I had so little time all of a
sudden I'll just go Kings side that's
Queen was scaring me a place ceefor shut
the bishop out
efore okay winning upon I have two to
zero in the center
let's get him rolling
three two zero three zero how am i
hanging out into that pond just push
them
okay I have a huge time lead g3 h3 falls
that's a freebie
probably should capture it the night
maybe not
okay okay they're down on time we gotta
go faster oh I might
the fire has been extinguished two two
two two
Oh still fishing for a 444 left here we
go 165 are in here okay
Jean power all right John power first
time playing John power oh they had on
put some the old on pass honor Oh a
pacman road watch out for pac-man chow
Oh Queen is cooked no she's not she has
to score aah
she has a square I didn't see that let's
just kill the night I don't care about
the dark square Bishop anymore my knight
wants to be on c5
I'm going to be in a pin check get to an
open file secure night open up a check
towards your own king
okay okay no no I'm going to resist
go after this guy
let's go here I'm up a piece why am i
playing like I'm down a piece oh man
oh man let's play with G for it I worked
out good last time
yeah right how did it end up I was down
a ton of time be fancy take my rook oh
that's a massive Fork
let's trade oh ooh
no they all fall where's the main main a
couple all right I got my clock I gotta
say oh man I gotta go faster
okay why keep putting the CARICOM
I'm in a lazy mode let's try this is
silly next time
something sharp
play something a little sharp
let's know okay let's do something fancy
gonna play off three no app three here
we go
just trying to blast open the kingside
somehow then gets collapsing yeah I take
with the Queen if I take with the rook
jeez real sting although I have Queen g5
I will take with the Queen
straightaway preparing to double is all
I'm up upon
okay centralize the king get rid of my
doubled pawn
I want my king to recapture I want to
keep these two around to control these
two I don't want them to create an
outside passed pawn next up d4 improve
the night watch out for Forks King and
pawn ending is winning okay there's my
extra C I could just squeeze the life
out of these ponds I'll take
let's keep going let's keep going
let's just hunt down this pawn now
do they have enough time to weave a
stalemate I don't think so it takes
forever they're just in the nick of time
okay the man the man the 16 is in there
whenever I see that name I think of
Carlson's nickname man in a van the man
the man we've played some we have played
some yak we've played some as well okay
probably should have just went for that
little trick in the center take on e5
and then follow up with the fork okay
let's I'm ready to take the knight and
then take upon yeah we could do that
when another pun keeping the pin
Kahless let's try this I'm not Castle
kingside yet can I get that bishop
okay I'll go kingside
King on h2
now let's go with let's go with that
form first let's go King here clean up -
mmm clean up - I want to keep this to
negate the rooks there we go now we
could slowly inch our King up I am down
on time in every game I feel like I'm
moving a lot faster but I'm not
my whining again there's no progress
over here for the rook he's a he's a
stuck rook
so now we collect pawns the rook has
some activity it's going to cost cost
them some material
let's just hide is threatening mate okay
get all the ponies
okay let's see if we could cut the King
off no stalemates no stalemates there we
go he's coming town this is not gonna go
well if I get the fast and furious one
I'm probably gonna get paired up with
the fast and furious one at some point
WB it's flawless oh my god Nicolay leach
s next opponent
all right I like this setup let's do it
No the rooks are connected enough I'll
take what the night yeah
avoid that exchange see I have this
square it's a huge square have time to
get these moves in I think I do
then where's that night going by the way
it's a huge structure where's that night
going fene keto tonight tough day for
the night tough day for the night
oh okay
take either Rokia wait for one to move
[ __ ] up here there's fearful of that
pawn kind of clamping down on my
structure
Queen exchange to fall in love with that
all I want to do put pressure on that
pond and I get right over this sea to
pond let's let's see if we
crack something open here see this is
where I start to drift on down ten
seconds
I had a pawn I had a pawn can I get the
Queen want the clean room for a clean
exchange
seven seconds man
you
for it's not quite me oh my god this the
only way to do it oh I'm going so slow
Oh
okay page 148 with fire slow down man
he's not in a game I'm probably gonna
get pretty ass here he is he's gonna do
is set up what do I do against this okay
I think this is the way forward
you
likes playing with the F pawn I know
that there's the F pawn there it is to
know that get rid of that light square
bishop
get rid of that let go here well that
square he's gonna watch out for that
backward pawn hmm okay I think this pawn
is a little ill I'm not mistaken how can
i how can i address that
make some progress on another wing we
can
want this break in my ruck controls -
checking squares from the Queen
is this working can't take with the
Queen I'm ready to push here I think
it's broken
I could take here no okay that's a big
passed pawn take here and then trade a
bunch prove the king
just a hair
let's see what kind of magic we could
work with here
think we got this one let's see
oh right here first
work here
you
10 seconds though so fast you hear my
mouth man are you loud shut up clunk
clunk clunk clunk clunk I can't even
make a clean move man oh man what kind
of mouse are you MX anywhere 2 did the
job but barely
aah oh I was too afraid to try and check
me it's too afraid to try checkmate
I figured my best way forward was the
time burn my way to victory and I had
one extra clunky mouse what do I want to
take with on my king is okay taken am i
winning upon I went in upon I thought I
was winning upon
take what am i doing um did you see this
is where I I spent so much time right
there 31 seconds
Wow
around the rook and the bishop probably
take my bishop no no they're not oh why
did I do that
mm-hmm fortunately I have that move wait
out on the clock that rook nearly dead
nearly okay they got a lot of pawns a
lot
and get get this bishop out of there and
improve my king
you
I've gotta go for a draw could I try to
win
no no no I'm gonna lose I'm gonna lose I
tried to be fancy there I should have
known better and just taking the pun oh
I wasn't even ahead on the clock I was
trying to be fancy I got out fancied I
hope fancied myself ah
hmm okay we still got 29 to go ah man
I really went into the tank on that one
move what move was that oh those are so
painful I should be converting these so
much better I'm not and I'm going slow
okay I got an isolated pawn
Bishop takes here not the first time
I've played this position type before
it's horrible oh man Claudia what do you
say give me the bishop pair
I don't know what I want to do let's
just waste nine seconds
well that's just ways to nine seconds
let's just give this pawn up as I wanna
maybe we do something against the king
huh wanna take with the pawn keep my
night central mm-hmm I'm not sure what
I'm doing with my ax
my pawn over here not sure at all
rook here Atlanta fork could try
hmm we can try
that's a free bishop now well how long
was that oh I was just there for one
move okay I give some material back
think have an edge on the clock Wow okay
Becca okay
mentally blind next opponent
okay gotta go faster
any great discoveries discovered attack
against my queen defend my bishop my
Knights free to move put pressure on
that pawn
felt a little weird taking the pond for
some reason want some trades first okay
let's let's back up
mmm yeah take oh let's take here they
gonna do that if I took with the bishop
that's what they're going to do
they would get mated 94 would have been
May in that case okay
I have that defended Queen g5 threads
mate let's defend
sneaky could do this though have my
queen defend Forks my queen is defended
port note gearing up for g3 hang on hang
on hang on hang on
that
night there is a move step up right here
so dangerous this night on f4 so
dangerous
get out of my house man holy cow is that
night so scary night on f4 a real killer
all right Ferrari has only slipped up
twice any drawers in there doesn't seem
like it they're paired WB and the
Ferrari orbit Ickx okay we just played a
little bit ago blitz on on e4
on b4 all right we're gonna we're gonna
go caveman
caveman-style
take
you
[Music]
let's see how they take here I have an
idea this and then here on sack and then
follow up with c5 by just giving away a
bunch of material it's not all I'm doing
maybe
it's going to be broken down
it's officially broken down
it's officially broken down Wow
gotta go here and this isn't reliable oh
I'm winning the night no the Queen has
to go to one of these too but I could I
could flush the Queen away Queen takes
here might even be a move I take the
night with check that's an important
detail my unite controls these three
Queen here my bishop has really lucked
out with that move really lucked out
swipe that pawn
sixty-five yes who knows which way I
should castle who would know that answer
what happens oh boy
Oh tongue-tied as usual Oh God
down on time okay Ferrari slipped up has
a boatload of points though 69 64 45 as
W being a game I don't see it we're
probably gonna get WB again see what
pieces I get WB no nope
okay
you
let us see
no future for this guy just yet by
winning upon
winning upon a five winning a huge
square B Five Forks I get my rook I get
their rook major piece ending
just take my Roca please
okay I feel like I could have done it a
little bit better there let's go here
defend the pond and put this guy in a
pin
save my rope
we win upon offer a queen exchange at
situ covered by central post
and defend save my queen
hide
allowing this I must blundered with
Queen here
okay I could take care and then come
back I just have a little check
and we just push push push push
not a lot of time I'll stalemates feel
like it's close to stalemate mate next
okay they're down on time
whoo
WB ya Ferrari won against WB and Ferrari
lost against WB o k WB again
all right let's try this
at the H pond plane okay okay at least
this isn't as familiar structure for WB
I think at least
yeah tough to assess this one to be sure
I want to control their light square
bishop if I can if you like my knight is
strong
my knight can do better whoo-hoo-hoo
right here actually it's a valuable dark
square bishop
very valuable soap in there um yes oh my
god my rook is hanging I totally didn't
see that
yikes my rook is hanging again oh man
drop in two rooks
okay two rooks too many once enough ah a
second one
mmm why don't I see that that Bishop was
on my rook I don't have answers okay how
do I get my king save how do we do it
very scary Oh God
I'm alive ha ha ha right you can't get
me show me this Knight is strong what a
tough guy
this Knight
defend squares Queen
hide
can't let you just give checking stuff
I want this pawn to super thorn I could
do this to replace the night and defend
my queen
normally that's a tactic but not here
aha out of the woods I thought
you
ah
and now making it difficult oh I had the
rook yeah take the free rook
took me a couple moves but I got the
rook okay let's see if we get third
these guys are battling it out for first
there can we get the podium and a try
fishy mcpot sir this isn't our first
time playing an open Sicilian okay fine
ok let's get dangerous with the f-bomb
why not be a centralizer
ready to push ready to push
let's do it
fake him out stay with the night
try and do something there oh okay some
weaknesses I should have captured with
the pawn
[Music]
you
yeah that queen is too active my coal
Queen side will fall
and Bishop is so strong
I need a flight square I'm way down on
the clock Oh God in big trouble
you
in big trouble
you
light squares I'm kinda weak on the
light squares
I'm nearly made it I would have been a
big fork
oh man
whose toast no time and no position
13 minutes ago Z is 21
hmm okay
let's go for the kill
let's go straight for the jugular if we
can
can we can we do that we can do that
okay let's try and play a little more
aggressive fishing pick spots are just
wanted to play you got enough let me
just get to a point where I get that
game in there and then we'll just we'll
just pause from there
we're gonna try to attack not gonna go
King side castle now we're gonna do a
rook we're gonna say this Knight is a
monster do something something different
like this like that
think that bishops just too good too
good that's what I think
something feels way off with that
get a pawn involved
got some material where's the mate
that's what I want to know
to check it's just a check
take the rook looking for something more
there it's block where is the mate
where's the mate breaking through here
now
okay 85 80 50 to 44
ten minutes and change
this game done I didn't see any moves
yes it is WB
um
okay here here here here
let's do it like okay I'm going for this
huh
okay
castle down the kingside
it's still a strong square what am i
doing
okay I have some squares to work with
some I don't know where I want a castle
I don't know what I want to do with my
King not quite sure
okay I'll go here
have that square covered
they missed that it's an easy one to
miss but definitely still a struggle
yes
you
okay I'm thinking that hits with check
that's not the case
my bishop
13 seconds
I want to keep my truck on the seventh
they want to do that
it's matin whew on two three so I got F
one who never an easy game never ever
look back on all our past games they're
never easy
always always always tough
okay
let's see if we could be aggressive in
this one to Queen c2 not Castle kingside
launch pawns on the kingside take this
check no 95 where is their king gonna go
yeah
okay
you
Bishop is strong clean exchange
this pawn is annoying Pamela Smith said
that they were there
Wow
Wow try and scoop oh my god did I really
just allow that I did I did
okay Wow our night is so good
move night okay oh they're really down
on time didn't realize that
didn't realize that he in a couple down
on time okay had some pressure there and
drop D for that was a big pond I would
say
who
WB again the white side so you gonna do
the same set up just the key on the
kingside is all
not quite
locked position I don't know where I
go it's my king
you
okay let's clamp down on that structure
now
I can't give this square up I could get
that in the rook is in a pin could take
care of its check in timely in-betweener
got a combat that night that's a blunder
King here I have that and then I take
the night just take stuff
I gave them the night back I could have
just went right back there
on the piece fortunately I have banked a
lot of material
King is close to mated very close
oh that was the last square for the king
okay
okay I think the biggest point there in
that game was the the kingside and if
they ever captured on e4 important now
for me to give up the G for square ever
every night was pointing there
everyone it's too big square too big
let's get that night out of here
now I take like this clean side play
just control the position no no no no
this is how you do it
and I'm not gonna put upon there I like
my night there we're gonna do something
exciting actually this night could be
more effective right here where he's
gonna try and blow stuff up now change
my mind of all day to try something and
this is going to be the something right
here right now mass exchanges king
invasion all the way and they did his
job is it to locked I got it I got a
pinpoint some other pawn this one given
material back huh
now I have a way
it's a good thing I had a point to
target
it's a good thing and now they all fall
ok last game coming up ooh WB was on a
tough stretch they both are in pause
mode so I guess I'm not going to get
either of them seemed to be locked in
there with third ok Nicolay we chess
almost certainly final game and one that
will
not count for the tournament standings
all right give me this square let's
let's kill pieces that control that and
one day have a strong night versus a bad
Bishop that's what we're hopeful hoping
for do we have a strong night versus a
bad bishop probably we can already call
it that - killer Knights
and now what challenge one I keep the
other dead Bishop which one do I want
let's keep out grip over the light
squares
I might want to run my king to the
queenside clean their pile up
ah free bishop remove
remove I had a free bishop now it's
going to collapse Bank the material our
material works don't allow any activity
plenty of time in the tank
and they resigned okay that's the last
one how many games was that
enough 23 they had 32 29 102 80 60 52 50
50 50 a battle for third place Ferrari
ran away with it there at the end
how many times did they play against
each other WB WB WB WB four five five
games against each other I didn't get
any against the Ferrari all right that
was page one 292 how many entered at
this was there at the start seemed like
just over a hundred could be off page
two three
nearly 300 it's a pretty big crowd
he stopped Lin
how many games to get in there
I only played ten thought I might get
some pairings with him if he was
playing throughout
didn't happen strong player it's another
one who always tough games
and I guess there's some who probably
didn't compete at all still seeing some
twos
yeah that's everybody oh no those who
did compete but just lost some games
okay to the 291 of you good games all
all right it's been a while to be sure
you